- [Instructor] Mario started
the day with five fire flowers.
He used some, and now only has three left.
If U is the number of flowers he's used,
we can write the following equation.
How many fire flowers did Mario use?
So he started with five,
he uses some of them.
So we subtract the number he used
and he ends up with three.
So there's a bunch of
ways that you could do it.
One way is you literally
could probably do this in your head.
Hey I took away some number
from five and I got three.
And you probably know,
hey well if I take two away
from five I'm gonna get three.
So he used two flowers.
The other way that you
could think about doing it
is a little, hey we got
only four options here.
Let me substitute each of them in here.
Maybe I was able to do
this one in my head,
but if I had something more complicated
let me try out these choices.
So if he only took zero away,
it'd five minus zero,
he'd still of course be left with five.
If he took one away,
then of course he'd only
have, he'd have four left.
If you took three away,
he'd have two left.
But if he took two away,
five minus two is indeed three.
And the third way,
you'll learn this as we go into more,
more of how, of the how of algebra
and also the why,
is that you could systematically solve it,
but we'll go into that in future videos.
So he used two fire flowers.